good morning Hank it's Wednesday I
really liked your ecosystem services
video on Monday and I learned a lot but
at one point in attempting to gently rib
me you experienced what I believe
sociologists refer to as epic fail let's
go to the tape you on the other hand
have some kind of froofy Bachelor of
Arts degree I don't even know what it's
in froofy Hank what's froofy by the way
I'm on my way to pick up my friend Chris
so I can go to xscape and get on the
frog hopper froofy I regret to inform
you is not a word I think you might have
meant fru-fru a French word meaning
frilly ornamentation something you might
have learned if you'd taken more Fine
Arts classes anyway later that same
video you jokingly said you can teach me
that the big billboard and the Great
Gatsby was like God or something
thumb thumb thumb now Hank unfortunately
you can't actually hear anything that
happened to xscape because along with
the sounds of my girlish screamin there
was the mellifluous tones of lady gaga
and lady gaga loves her copyright but
about that billboard Hank it isn't
actually the Billboard that's a metaphor
for God okay hold on just a little bit
of girlish screamin
the metaphor for God is the disembodied
bespectacled eyes depicted on that
billboard Hank as I mentioned last week
when I was growing up I felt that
mathematics was this arbitrary set of
rules that had been created for the
express purpose of hurting my feelings
and when a lot of people read literature
critically they feel similarly they
think why are we even talking about this
who knows if the author intended it all
you're doing is wasting our time I would
argue that the study of English
literature is not near so boring and
inconsequential as masters of science
like you would have us believe God it
felt so good to get off that frog up or
by the way the girl operating the frog
hopper said that I was the biggest guy
she'd ever seen on it
thanks anyway what's interesting about
the metaphor of the huge eyes is not the
metaphor itself but its implications so
in the great gatsby a number of very
important plot elements happen directly
beneath the gaze of these gigantic
bespectacled eyes also at the end of the
book the only person who's there for
Gatsby other than Nick and Gatsby's
father is Owl Eyes a character we know
nothing about except that he has big
eyes and glasses also he is God Hank I'm
happy to acknowledge that none of that
is inherently interesting but it is
interesting to think about justice and
fairness and the way that socioeconomic
class shape our understandings of
justice and it's interesting to think of
God as two huge disembodied eyes with
glasses because what do eyes do they see
good job smartypants what else do they
do mmm they blink not when they're
making videos they don't yeah I guess
eyes really don't do much other than see
and that in the broader context of the
novel is very interesting no spoilers
here but if you've read the Great Gatsby
and possibly even if you haven't you
might have noticed that life isn't
always fair and sometimes bad people
don't get what's coming to them and that
in fact wealth and social standing can
significantly improve your chances of
not getting what's coming to you and
it's a huge challenge to live in this
unjust world without to borrow a line
from Nick closing out your interest in
the aborted sorrows and the short winded
ovations of men Hank I think in those
disembodied eyes Fitzgerald is arguing
that God is in the seeing business but
he's not in the doing business I think
the question of to what extent the
universe or God is aware of and
interested in the abortive sorrows and
short-winded elations of man is a very
interesting question and we see people
who haven't read the great gatsby
closely doing a poor job of thinking
about this stuff
all the time like for instance just
today the televangelist Pat Robertson
was trying to make sense of why
who is active in the world would allow
the worst possible earthquake in the
worst possible place on earth and he
said that a while ago the Haitians made
a deal with the devil and now they were
getting their pay back well obviously
that's stupid hanket but I would argue
that stupidity is born out of bad
reading bad teaching and bad thinking
and what I think a liberal arts
education does well is it teaches you
what to think about what I love most
about reading critically is the same
thing I love most about math it helps me
to learn what's interesting and it
forces me to grapple seriously and
complexly with a world that is not as it
should be in short Hank I would argue
that it's because I have a liberal arts
education and because I've spent time
thinking about the eyes on that
billboard that I'm able to listen to you
talk for four minutes about something I
don't understand yet also I get to know
the meaning of the word fru-fru I'll see
you on Friday